you went to your high school reunion am
I correct I sure did yeah yeah I was
that you fantastic
yeah high school you don't go to yours I
did I did I did go to you're a jerk no
no I didn't know I'm saying I did go to
my high school reunion and back in
Brookline Massachusetts and people kept
coming up and saying it was really thick
Boston accents one guy was convinced
that he and I had robbed a liquor store
together and let me just tell you
something I was the square person ever
at that age and probably still am now
and this guy was like remember that time
you and I rubbed that liquor store
remember that and then the cops came and
we went out the back window remember
that and then I got copy you got away
with all the booze and you drank it you
son of a [ __ ] you but I said none of
that happens like Oh mr. TVs gonna clean
it up and that's when I said I can't go
back people have invented reason of it
that's what that's what I mad Esther I
grew up Modesto California yeah no way
yeah get out what high school yeah
that's what I'm talking about buddy high
school man my core audience tends to
have skipped high school yeah all right
Fred super high right here yeah yeah I
know uh you know that's what's like was
like that we just hang out with your
buddies generally just talk about
remember you know did you do goofy
things all right kid but that's still oh
my god yeah it's like you know it's
American Graffiti it's like it was just
like American Graffiti that's it was
Lucas grew up in Modesto that movies
based on I don't know if you anyone's
seen it but it's a class that we teach a
class cruise up and down McKenna that's
my that's my you know teenage years were
like just you know ugly your car's just
right you know Volkswagen and there's
just a lot of you know combating it's a
fine line between sort of creative
teenage inventiveness to combat boredom
and oh [ __ ] I think we might go to
prison you know it's that kind of that
child yeah it's sort of like oh we're
being kind of Rascals right now or that
got out of hand
yeah you're just like driving up and
down the kenri you know what are we
gonna do we drive up and down McKenna
we pull people over for directions and
then hit them with the fire
extinguishers
wow that is what you'd say can I can I
get directions they come ha ha ha ha
you're blinded for life that hip trap
we had a Mannix down the street had a
dummy we used to we have this dummy in
their garage that was newspaper and
walnut and then he was closed and made
anew and with the walnuts and so if
anyone actually did run him over it
would sound like that broke his legs you
know she would just what would you do we
throw them into traffic we were like
that's hilarious we've take him out in
the street we'd beat him up and wait for
cars to come and then they would leave
him in the street and they'd get out and
be like oh my god they thought they'd
come across some guy the father goes in
to put walnuts in the legs yeah so it
sounds like Legos they're a hit it's got
a little right right people are trying
to give it medical attention you run out
and shoot him in the end we gift-wrapped
cinderblocks during the holidays and
just left him out on the street for what
does that do it's just fun to watch
people pick up a cinder block thinking
it's a gift
and then sometimes there's always some
[ __ ] who's like sees it and wants to
run it over because there's just that
kind of people and yes though you know
what I'm talking about yeah and then and
then if that guy chooses to be I mean
some guy in some lowered Camaro would
just like burnt boom tag it and they
were just totally up his transmission
and then yeah and then he run in your
yard because that guy's the [ __ ]
I squawking who's the go ice-blocking
ice-blocking do you ever go ice-blocking
yeah we go out to ice-blocking either go
out to Del Rio or Oakdale golf course
they got the te set up with it you know
like at midnight when every party's been
shut down and you either gonna drink in
the park oh you're gonna go out to the
golf course and go ice-blocking you stop
off at 7-eleven you get the blocks of
ice everyone's always got sweatshirts
and stuff in their back in case we
decide to go ice-blocking a point and
you go up and you sit on the green with
a case of beer and you slide down the
fairway on the block size and it's not
it's not good for the fairways but it's
a lot of fun it really sounds to me like
you grew up in the late 1920s this is
this is really does sound like you're a
young guy right what we used to do and
then the best corn husks would give them
to the donkey and watch him have
diarrhea
it's called diarrhea ink if we get
really lucky the golfcourse cop shows up
in his golf cart uh-huh and you get him
to chase you know and the whole thing is
to try to get him out of the cart yeah
and one of us circles back and takes the
spotlight off the car yeah because if
you can get the spotlight now you got
more hours of fun back on McHenry coming
up behind people with the big spotlight
on there you're just a criminal that's
all you are I preface this whole story
with it's a fine line I told you the
front Tamura Timothy as you prefer to be
called it's your contract
I'd love to talk more about these tricks
you pulled during the president Hoover
administration but we have got to get to
a clip from the santa clarita diet
because we we have got to show a clip
I'm not the one to rob the liquor store
we don't talk about that anymore that's
where people we draw the line right now
exactly I know I got ol arias though is
that store like this you robbing a
liquor store could only help you yeah
you know a story it would only make me
seem cooler right exactly because I
later got a talk show people have all
these myths about me from back in
Brooklyn like I hear a cop cut out a
line and you punched him out what I'm
coating over ahead I couldn't fight a
butterfly yeah
you